wow an exterminator um
i have to say i i admire i mean first of
all exterminators are are much in need i
i don't know that i could do that job
you know i don't think you could either
i mean i love you but i really don't
think you could cut it
wait a minute okay well now
now i'm pissed rose what do you mean i
couldn't cut it how couldn't i cut it
well i i just haven't why do you say
that about me let's say i hadn't said
that conan
of you running and screaming with your
little backpack sprayer you know up and
down the lawn your little backpacks
well
it's a little
uh well i don't i'm not saying you're
wrong
i mean i'm mad at you for calling me out
on it
but i think i will wow rose i love that
you have tough love anyone who's
you've had your your
your legs replaced 35 times yes
so you're in no mood to cuddle a random
idiot that you're talking to that's um
that's true i think i would
i would be uh creeped out by it i think
i would be now you know what's
interesting to me is that
i'm not a fan of a bug in uh my regular
civilian life but for many years on
television i had to hold reptiles and
rodents and bugs
during uh segments like that those sort
of animal segments and if it was in
front of an audience i didn't have any
fear i don't know why but if i thought
it could be funny
i'd put a bug in my mouth i'd hold a i'd
wrap a snake around my neck i just i did
stuff that was probably looking back on
it really stupid but i have none of that
bravery when there's no audience i don't
know what that's all about and that's i
think that's what drives me working with
men especially is feeling like i need to
prove myself in some form
um like when i had first applied for the
job my husband just cackled and was like
you can't do that and i was like [ __ ]
watch hold my beer i'm gonna do this
good for you
rose i do not think you need to prove
yourself to anybody
you've done it you have done yeah you
have uh
never ever in your life i mean you're a
very impressive uh you're a warrior
you're a warrior rose so uh i respect
you and i'll be honest i also
fear you if i was a rat in the basement
and you came down there
uh i would be terrified do you do rats
and mice or just plugs yeah yeah we do
rodents nothing bigger than a rat you
know anything bigger than that you have
to call wildlife to come take care of
that have you ever fought it out with a
rat in person or is it always just you
know leaving some poison cheese behind
poison cheese
i'm sorry that's how i let not hug
just assume that's how it's done
here rat have some cheese i feel like i
feel like you would get hungry at some
point and think hey i'll be fine i'll
take a little nipple
i probably would i'd say i don't think i
would die i would just
bleed out of every orifice for a while
and then
i call that a thursday uh
so what um
you know what's your did you ever
encounter one like you're looking at it
and it's looking at you and it's it's go
time or is it always leave the glue trap
or whatever and take off it's mostly
just leaving bait around i've seen ones
that have gotten into my bait and kind
of just staring at me they you know are
pretty lethargic and they'll look at you
and all you could say is sorry buddy
just keep walking
right but nothing nothing physical yet
right i think i'd carry a handgun that
was an english there you go
yeah i mean
quick and painless right i mean for
myself oh okay okay
just take and the minute i saw something
[Laughter]
a water bug
first day on the job